if you actually quantify what's been
happening as we've been using more
fossil fuels emitting more co2 we can
document how many people are dying from
climate-related disasters such as storms
and flood extreme temperatures and the
rate of climate-related disaster that's
is down 98 over the last century it's
crazy like we're so much safer from
climate than we used to be and yet
nobody talks about this
alex epstein welcome to the show good to
see you again good to see you again how
are you
i am good we got to meet in person a
couple months ago which is which is fun
one hell of an adventure you took us out
on palmer lucky's
ex navy seals extraction boat that does
60 knots and we
terrified everybody in lido lido isle
lido isle yeah newport beach
yeah that was funny so it's saturday
morning
and we're pulling out of this sort of
beautiful bay and there's people on
kayaks and paddle boarding and doing
little like pedal things and then
there's people on party boats and then
there's this huge big gray
monster
with
50 cal machine guns with no ammunition
mounted on the sides of it and we're
just slowly chugging along next to them
that was
a sight to behold
yeah i don't know if your listeners ever
heard but yeah you were you were nice
enough to come out and and be the
interviewer for this thing i did with
peter thiel uh and palmer lucky for the
launch of the event and
yeah since palmer had graciously agreed
to host it and if people don't know who
palmer is he's a very impressive guy
uh he
founded oculus and sold it to facebook
for over two billion dollars when he was
21 and then got fired from facebook
mostly related to
giving less than ten thousand dollars to
a pro trump
uh group and then he started a very
successful really cool defense startup
so he's very interested very into
defense very into technology very into
weapons
and uh he yeah he's a kind of fan of my
work and so he agreed to host this event
and peter was on the stage and you came
and he's like oh i have this mark v navy
seal boat so why don't you guys take a
ride on that and go visit an offshore
short oil platform so
it's nice to have acquaintances who uh
have cool ideas and the means to execute
them and cool toys that you can
piss about yeah we got to drive it a
little bit we got to steer it yeah
as well
for sure
yeah wild one of the wildest pieces of
kit and the guys were telling us about
how
so you can imagine the back of this boat
uh opens down kind of like a low loader
on a u-haul or something but this opens
down into the water so the navy seals
that are being extracted from wherever
they've just kicked in some doors and
got some bad guys or whatever they get
onto the little sort of rubber dinghy
crafts and they'll blast along and they
don't even slow down apparently they
just hit the back of this boat and slide
up straight onto it come to a halt all
the guys get out some of them get onto
the um
belt fed 50 cal machine guns some of
them strapped themselves in some of them
go and do some other stuff it's like it
was it was pretty cool it was pretty
pretty cool
yeah so it was uh fun to have you and i
i wish that was every weekend maybe it's
every weekend for valmer but yeah it's a
very very uh unusual experience for me
billionaire
21 year old
well now he's 29 now he's 29. imagine
that all right so
fuel and energy prices uh yes pretty
wild at the moment can you explain
what's going on why they're so high
so i i think of this as a situation
that's very simple in its fundamentals
and
i think the complexity is mostly that
the people who caused the problem are
trying to evade responsibility
for the problem so i mean just think
about in economics if you just heard
like prices go up what do you expect
right it has to be a change of supply
and demand supply sets prices right so
is it you know supply goes down demand
goes up or we know one of the two or
worse both from for purposes of prices
then you're gonna get rising prices and
so what what is the thing we're
concerned with the supply and demand of
well it's fossil fuels it's oil prices
which directly affect gasoline prices
but it's also natural gas prices which
have been going up around the world
which has which have huge implications
including in fertilizer and that leads
to food shortages and threats of
starvation and then coal prices also um
are at very you know recent highs coal
prices are usually stable and they have
been quite high and that affects many
people affects industry including many
of the poorest people around the world
who use a lot of coal um in developing
economies
so
if you think about okay so prices are
set by supply and demand and so we're
worried about fossil fuels well what in
the world could have happened with
fossil fuels that might suppress the
supply of fossil fuels i don't know
maybe the number one most influential
moral movement in the world
is focused on eliminating fossil fuels
so the reason my views are controversial
is because we have this global movement
that says we need to achieve what's
called net zero
by 2050 which means essentially
eliminating fossil fuel use now it's the
middle
of 2022 and for at least the past 15
years this movement has been quite
successful and increasingly i should say
in recent years at opposing fossil fuel
investment fossil fuel production fossil
fuel transportation and we see this in
the united states we have many examples
of all of these you certainly see it
even more in europe we could go into the
examples but i think people are pretty
familiar and then what we have at the
same time so we have suppressing supply
by opposing investment production
transportation
and then what happens with demand well
part of the the
premise or i would argue pretense
of restricting the supply of fossil fuel
is oh well we can rapidly replace them
with solar and wind and you see a lot of
investments and subsidies and mandates
going that direction and what's happened
is that has turned out not to be the
case and so once you're out of a
pandemic
lockdown where demand is artificially
suppressed demand comes back it starts
increasing but supply has been
suppressed and there was a kind of
record amount of enthusiasm for
suppressing supply
during the pandemic because there was
this lie that oh demand has gone down so
it'll always go down so you had a lot of
like the esg movement at its peak saying
no more investments you have the
international energy agency saying we
shouldn't be developing if we want to
hit these targets we shouldn't be
developing new oil and gas and what you
saw for example is a huge suppression of
say oil investment which went down 50
from 2011 to 2021 and this is in a world
that needs more of it and i had been
arguing for many years that look the
world is desperately short of energy six
billion people use a level of energy
that you and i would consider
unacceptable three billion people use
less electricity specifically than a
typical american refrigerator a third of
the world uses wood and animal dung as
their dominant source for heating and
cooking we live in an energy starved
world from our perspective and for most
people's perspective like as in they
want the energy that we have and so that
means massively more energy demand and
i've argued that fossil fuels will for a
long time be uniquely able to supply
low-cost reliable energy for all the
different types of machines on a global
scale so if you have a desperate need
for something a unique ability to
provide it you suppress the supply the
demand goes up you get this price crisis
so i think there's there's a lot of
arguments that people make but i think
it's very simple supply and demand
what is the reason that's given by
people that are
not pro fossil fuels presumably let's
say that this is true actually is there
anything else
beyond the suppression of investment
which has restricted the supply
is that are there any other elements
that have impacted the availability and
the prices of fuel and stuff at the
moment yes yes but i think they're
they're derivative and
not decisive but so one
there a lot i think are totally invalid
that are
pseudo reasons but one is if you like
say the american industry in particular
there was over investment
in what's called american shale energy
so shale rock you know is this is this
rock that was historically useless that
in the past two decades american
industry in particular ingeniously
allowed to become economic in terms of
producing oil and gas you look back in
the 50s and 60s and 70s this was
considered
uh impossible or in the future for
example my favorite book atlas shrugged
by iran one of the heroes is somebody
who figures out how to get shale to work
which is not something that could
actually be done but then we have these
real life heroes who actually did it
part of what happened is and and we
could talk about the reasons behind this
so much money got put in shale
that you oversupplied the market
arguably given given the um the actual
economics and so a lot of investors lost
money on that and so what they told the
companies is hey you need more what they
would call fiscal discipline so you need
to you should not over invest
uh if there's a chance that you'll lose
money and so the the level of so that
has driven some of the unwillingness to
invest uh but at the same time a lot of
it has been what's called this esg
movement environmental social governance
which is just a um
quasi-gov half-government half-voluntary
uh in this context aspect of the
anti-fossil fuel movement where they're
telling companies hey commit to net zero
investors commit to net zero and you
have many many successful companies that
have said hey i've got this profitable
course of action and say university
endowments won't touch it or major
financial institutions won't touch it
and so that's that what happened is the
um
the at the the fact that the industry
wasn't doing well financially or parts
of it weren't doing well financially
that actually gave fuel to the fire of
esg because it the esg people said hey
look if you invest in oil you're going
to lose money so even more people made
these anti-oil commitments and so that
it made things even worse so versus a
small correction where you said oh we
over invested okay let's pull back a bit
people pulled back massively
uh with with the the failu the the um
the failed investments as a pretext but
really being driven by this anti-fossil
fuel movement
give me your thoughts on the modern esg
movement
well you know one thing that's exciting
is there are finally people
against this thing which i felt pretty
alone in uh for a couple years so so
just so people know esg stands for
environmental social
and governance and essentially what it
what it purports to be which i think
everyone should consider absurd on the
face of it
is it says these are the universal norms
that every company should follow so here
kind of the environmental norms you
should follow here are the social norms
which can include things like skin color
how you deal with that how you deal with
communities and then governance
practices and one thing is this was a
lot of this was cooked up at the un
which you wouldn't think of as these are
experts in how to have a successful
business
and so what it's
what it and i guess the broader thing of
esg is it's part of what's called
stakeholder capitalism and so this is
the idea that the primary purpose of the
company and its management should not be
to produce value profitably but to
broadly serve stakeholders and then that
will somehow lead to profit and the
issue there is stakeholders has no real
definition so when you whereas profit is
clear right you you have a certain input
and then you can sell it your output for
a certain amount and then the difference
is profit and so it really holds you to
you need to create value you need to you
need to uh put out more than you put in
but with stakeholder it can be anything
and so what this leaves you open to is
uh whatever are the popular moral or
political views at the time that's what
decides the stakeholders and that's what
decides what's a good environmental
practice what's good social what's good
governance so if you take social for
example i would argue that racism in the
true sense of it is a major guiding
principle of esg today that as they
believe that skin color is extremely
important and that you should be
required to have a certain balance of
skin colors in your company or that you
should have a certain like gender
requirement of this many people on your
board and i think that's well in the
race case i think that's a racist view
that views ideas as determined by skin
color but in any case that's a
particular view that is treated as oh
this is what everyone should do socially
and notice you get these monolithic
practices where all the companies are
doing the same things and you can't
question them and so that's what that's
esg these you allegedly universal norms
that everyone follows and then an
environment shouldn't be a surprise to
most people given the dominance of the
anti-fossil fuel movement that to be
good environmentally overwhelmingly
means you commit to rapidly eliminating
your fossil fuel use and that in your
supply chain and so the esg movement its
number one practical consequence
economically has been companies around
the world committing to
net zero to getting off fossil fuels to
sometimes using all solar and wind and i
think that has been a total disaster
why is it that companies would follow
this
type of advice
when it seems to be the sort of thing
that's going to cause their
profit lines to drop down
it's a really good question so one thing
we see is that it's mostly or it's
dominated in parts of company or rather
among it's dominant among companies that
are most connected to
governments so when you're thinking
about let's just say say the esg is the
biggest in public companies
so public companies that's not a totally
free thing because you have exchanges
that you have to be on and there's all
kinds of government regulation and
government pressure and so there are a
lot of financial advantages to being a
public company namely it's much easier
to raise money it's easier to
incentivize people to be part of it
because you become very liquid right
like if i join a private company it can
be hard to sell my shares that's less of
an incentive to join it if i join a
public company like if i'm part of nike
and i have a big stake of nike i can
sell that on the public markets there's
a lot of reasons to want to go public
but then what these movements like esg
do is they attach themselves to these uh
institutions often that have close their
approximate to governments and so they
get they get different kinds of
incentives and policies passed that way
so there's there's one thing of the more
the government is involved the more the
companies tend to adopt these kinds of
of practices
um another thing is that there's just a
lot of status seeking
in the corporate world and you know one
thing one thing um
in the in what's called the theory of
the corporation that's really important
is corporation is this amazing thing but
it always has what's called there are
different ways of putting this like the
agency problem but the issue of you have
a division between ownership and control
so the people who own the company are
different from the people who control
the company and there's this legitimate
perennial worry about how do you get the
people who control the company to act in
the interests of the owners of the
company and this is a huge challenge
throughout corporate history like if you
if you own all the company yourself and
you control it that can be the best for
the company but that often is not the
situation certainly the founder dies or
there are many situations where you
don't even have that in the in the first
place and so what you need to watch out
for is what bad incentives do the agents
have namely the managers of the company
that are at odds with the corporation
and one huge one which relates to esg
is that a huge percentage of
shareholders today
are not owners in the conventional sense
of people who choose to own the company
because they think it's promising and to
believe in its mission they're what are
called passive investors namely in the
form of index fund so an index fund is
something that's a great innovation and
you get it from vanguard or blackrock or
state street and the idea is that
instead of picking securities yourself
stocks yourself you invest in the
broader market to um so that you you can
take advantage of the fact that over
time the market performs well it's very
hard to pick so i have a lot of index
funds a lot of people have a lot of
index funds but there's a tricky issue
of when you're in an index fund so if i
and let's say my i've i'm in something
called dimensional but let's say i'm in
vanguard which i used to be in you know
vanguard i i hold hundreds of different
companies through vanguard so do i vote
those shares myself well usually what's
happened for various reasons is vanguard
votes those shares on my behalf and on
other others behave so you look at
companies like exxon mobil
chevron they have huge shareholder
ownership
by blackrock by vanguard by state street
and therefore those people can exercise
enormous ownership issues but even
though they're not traditional owners
and so those people then what's then the
managers of those companies can sort of
be the owners of every company and their
agendas can screw with everyone so an
example this guy larry fink whom we
talked about peter and i talked about at
our event
uh like he he has an insane amount of
control over the entire corporate world
because he runs blackrock and blackrock
owns so much of every company so he can
write a letter to ceos and every ceo has
to be afraid of him and he is very you
know he's kind of a politically left guy
he is very obsessed historically with
this net zero movement with climate
catastrophe and his political ideas
therefore have an enormous influence on
all of corporate uh america even though
i'd argue
uh you for many reasons you wouldn't
want that influence
and and i would argue he's totally
ignorant about energy and and uh also
has ideas about energy in any case has
ideas about energy that are not good for
the world
speaking about fossil fuels and energy
and net zero
what novel about your argument that says
that we should embrace more fossil fuels
because dr patrick moore was on here a
while ago and he was talking about
a little bit more of a um i guess a
geothermal look at what was happening
anthropologically in the data what were
you expecting in terms of global warming
what's unique about or novel about your
position
well i'm glad that's a question now
because i don't think it would have been
a question when i got started 15 years
ago because almost nobody was arguing
for
fossil fuels so
first of all there are not nearly enough
people arguing for fossil fuels and then
i would say the people who are arguing
somewhat for fossil fuels are not
usually arguing
as consistently as i am so that the
views kind of are we need to rapidly
eliminate fossil fuels
or we need to slowly eliminate fossil
fuels but in any case we should be
focused on getting off fossil fuels and
my my conclusion i'll talk about the
argument in a second is no we should be
expanding
fossil fuels so one thing is just the
conclusion so it's it's the book is
fossil future why global human
flourishing requires more oil coal and
natural gas not less so it's really
saying the world should have more
um
and i think the the key to it is
that i
have a very explicit framework that i
think you need to think about these
issues with and so the first
differentiating thing is not to be too
modest but i don't think anyone else
really has a fully worked out framework
and i think that the better people who
are closer to me have somewhat of a
framework like they'll talk about
cost-benefit analysis um
but i think to think about these issues
like leaving aside the conclusion to
think about these issues you need to be
really clear
on three core
issues
and the context these are we're talking
about like fossil fuels are they good
for the world are they bad for the world
what should we do about them
the real kids like what should we do
about this source of energy that
provides most of the world's energy but
also emits co2 and so we have concerns
like what should we do and i think the
the three things you need to think about
are one what is your goal
when you're talking about this issue
like when you're talking about the world
as a whole what is your goal like what
would it mean to to move forward versus
move backward and i think and we can
dive into these but i'll just give the
highlight the high level it's like
there's i think there's a fundamental
question of is your goal to
eliminate human impact on earth or
advance human flourishing on earth and i
think the dominant way of thinking about
it which you see a lot in climate is our
goal should be to eliminate our impact
on earth as much as possible and i think
of that i think it's an anti-human
unjustifiable goal so that's kind of one
thing um number two which is related is
sort of what's your view of the
relationship between human beings uh and
earth and i think the the the the
alternatives are one it's what i call
the delicate nurture view of earth which
is the idea that the earth exists in a
delicate nurturing balance that's stable
sufficient and safe and that human
impact ruins it for humans and for the
rest of nature since the idea of the
earth is kind of perfect and our impact
ruins it
versus and i think there's no there's no
basis of that for that at all and i
think the actual true is what i call the
wild potential view of earth so which is
that the earth has the potential to be
an amazing place but it's it's
unimpacted state it's dynamic deficient
and dangerous and so human beings need
to massively impact it or i would call
it productively impacted for it to be an
abundant and safe place for humans so
there's there's what's your goal with
respect to the earth what's your view of
the relationship between human beings on
earth and then i think what flows from
that is what i call your method of
evaluation and so
here when you look at
how people look at fossil fuels i would
argue that they tend to
ignore the benefits of fossil fuels and
overstate or certainly only pay
attention to the side effects so i give
the example in my book of one of our
leading thinkers on this issue michael
mann he talks about fossil fuels and
climate and agriculture and he talks
only about negative impacts on
agriculture but he doesn't mention once
in his long book that fossil fuels are
crucial for food for fertilizer and for
all the amazing agricultural machines
and it's thinking like that that causes
us to have an energy crisis because we
ignore the benefits and so we throw away
fossil fuels without realizing what
we're using so that's a very i argue
that's pervasive among our leaders is
ignoring the benefits
and then only paying attention to or
actually wildly overstating the side
effects and then the proper thing is you
need to look you need to equally weigh
the benefits and the side effects right
you need to weigh them both with
precision um and so i think those are
those are the kind of the three big
issues do you believe that our goal is
to eliminate human impact on earth or
advance human flourishing on earth do
you believe that earth is a delicate
nurture a wild potential
and do you just look at the negative
side effects or do you look at both
benefits and negative side effects and
in fossil fuel i do is lay that out
really clearly and i show hey this is my
framework this is the framework that
most of our leading thinkers are using
they can't defend that framework nobody
can defend this framework what they're
relying on is that it's implicit and
that they're never actually stating
their framework and so my goal what i
say is here's my framework which i call
the human flourishing framework if we
apply that framework to fossil fuels
it's obvious that we should use more so
i think ninety percent of this is
is uh
is philosophy that's part of why i think
i've been able to make a unique
contribution because of a background as
a pro-human philosopher particularly
environmental pro-human environmental
philosopher and i think once you have
the right philosophical framework
my my position is essentially obvious
you you can you can argue about degrees
but the idea of net zero is it that is
like saying let's have 10 holocausts
why
well because
because um human beings
eight billion people only survive
by the grace of having
millions of amazing machines that make
us productive and prosperous and that
protect us from the naturally deficient
and dangerous earth and we're seeing
this right now with agriculture right
where we're having literal talk of
starvation now around the world but you
take agriculture like the only way of
the earth supports 8 billion people with
all this food is we have all these
amazing machines often powered by diesel
that can allow one person to do as much
work as a thousand really good manual
laborers used to be able to do and we
have things like fertilizer that allow
us to overcome the pretty naturally
meager amount of say bat guano
that's on the earth and these are
powered by fossil fuels namely oil for
the machines and natural gas for the
fertilizer and so
if you
reduce it like if you actually eliminate
those without a viable replacement on
the on the timetable we were talking
about that's literally killing people
and you know far more than i mean far
more people die prematurely than from 10
holocausts now like i think that's just
that's just what would happen now
people can say well it's not going to
happen it's not going to happen that way
which is true
but it's still important to know
bad stuff will happen as we're seeing
now but it's still important to know
that the goal is bad
like and you really need to i and when
you don't identify the goal is bad by
the way then you get things like
holocausts because you get somebody
saying yeah it would be really good if
there weren't all these jews and people
like yeah
or like yeah maybe that's going too far
but i don't really like jews
that much you know they have i don't
like that i don't like these bankers and
stuff i mean that's a lot of what you
had with hitler is a lot of his goals
were announced
and um
but in particular the goal of like let's
eliminate the jews like that was
considered a reasonable goal like these
people are bad and
let's eliminate fossil fuels as a goal
like that's not something we should
civilize people should be talking about
well the difference is that
the immediate effect of eliminating
fossil fuels aren't
so present right it's not a person it's
not some sentient being that you're
hurting so the most compelling thing and
obviously we did this event and it meant
that i went back into your old work and
then into your new work as well i think
the most compelling argument that i saw
was this sort of
bourgeois
very fortunate very um luxurious
position that most of the people who are
putting forward these policies and these
ideas are coming from so a lot of the
time this is western highly developed
civilizations places that have got
infrastructure with clean
well not clean but cheap and reliable
energy right that people can get access
to at all times and they're saying we
need to reduce our fossil fuel use this
is bad this is going to endanger the
environment we're going to have climate
catastrophes
meanwhile
three billion people on the planet don't
have access to
regular
available energy like it's right
policies being put in place by people
who are not going to be impacted
by those policies like yeah sure maybe
the price is going to go up but they're
not going to lose access to energy
overall and that
um
like the the
distance between the people that are
pushing this and implementing this and
how it's going to impact them and the
people that it's genuinely going to make
a ton of an impact on the ones that
desperately need more and more
energy that was the most compelling uh
part of it for me
so i think i partially agree with you
but but not fully on the immediacy so so
for sure to the point i mean obviously i
make the points i agree with it about
you like my view is you need to con when
you're thinking about the world you need
to constantly think about most people
are really poor
and from your perspective
live in an apocalypse
like and palmer lucky and i talked about
this after the event we had a little 10
minute um
uh discussion um that's by the way on my
sub stack alex epstein dot sub stuck dot
com and like he and i both resonated
with this point that like if you if you
lived in a world where you're making
less than ten dollars a day like if you
got transported there and everything
that entails you'd be like oh my gosh
what the hell happened like this would
be horrific and so you just need to
constantly thinking be thinking most
people are poor
and they're poor because nature makes us
poor and because they're not productive
and they're not productive because they
don't have machines and without low-cost
reliable energy they can't use machines
so you just
like you think about that all the time
and you're right that so many people in
the west don't think about this but
it's what really what's happening i
think with the um
with this issue of it's not immediate
the main thing until recently is we
haven't really been following the
policies so we've been talking about so
this is the weird paradox where people
say oh my gosh alex you're so crazy
you're for fossil fuels but the world
has been in world's been agreeing with
me in practice like i say i love fossil
fuels people think that's crazy but the
world has been using more and more
fossil fuels fossil fuel use has been
increasing globally uh indefinitely just
with the pandemic being the drop
but that was that wasn't lack of fossil
fuels that was just lack of energy and
every everything in society being
being suppressed and so what we see is
even in the wealthy world when we have
any kind of supply issue as we're having
now or certainly any reliability issue
as we've had in california texas people
experience that as disastrous and they
don't want anything to do with it so
what's happened is it's it's more that
like once you have energy problems it's
true that some of them take a while to
play out but a lot of them are immediate
because the machines require continuous
energy like as soon as the energy stops
it's not like it stops and then five
years later you notice now you notice
like five seconds later when it's
electricity and you notice five days
later if it's anything else
in in the world of energy like imagine
you're new york
and
truck stop working you will notice very
very quickly so
it just shows how reckless these are i
mean they're terrible for the poorest
people in the world but even for rich
people once your supply of continuous
energy is disrupted life is terrible and
that's that's part of what makes me
optimistic is now people are actually
seeing
hey we have an energy crisis and they
don't like it and the biden
administration everyone else are like
they're really backtracking
a lot on their on their policies but the
most common pushback against this surely
would be we don't need fossil fuels we
can recreate this energy with renewables
which are right cleaner and not going to
impact the environment we get to have
our cake and eat it too we get to get
energy and we get to reduce our impact
on the environment
right yeah and then so this is this is
um
i think this is now becoming less
plausible to people because of the event
so so it's important that
this has been the basis
of restricting fossil fuel use for the
last
uh x number of years has been to say
yeah we can replace it with solar and
wind so for example why does europe ban
fracking which is you know the most
effective energy technology
of the last 20 years we think we don't
need fracking right i mean well yeah
we'll get some gas from russia and
hopefully that'll work out well but they
don't feel like they need it right
there's all why are all these companies
getting off oil because they think look
we don't need it we're just going to
have so-called renewables which in
practice means mostly solar wind and so
i think that that people should i can
give the the logic of why it doesn't
work but it's important that it's not
working i mean it's hard to say it's
hard to say oh we haven't done anything
with these we haven't subsidized them we
haven't mandated them there's been an
aggressive global push to use as many of
these as possible
and yet what's happened is clearly they
haven't made up
the difference because this the
shortfall of fossil fuel supply has led
to rising prices whereas if if
renewables could substitute then you
wouldn't have the rising prices but what
if people said that's just because we
don't have enough renewables yet we
haven't implemented sufficient solar and
wind yeah yeah so that that's i mean
you could think that but then it's it's
also interesting just on the surface
that
what it what is everyone doing like
biden is not saying hey
he's not primarily saying hey china give
me some more solar panels he's saying
like venezuela give me some more oil
saudi arabia give me some more well so
i'm just giving these are just
indications i mean the basic thing is
so
fossil fuels provide 80 of the world's
energy in a world that's desperately
short of energy uh they provide
uniquely versatile energy so they power
a much wider variety of machines than
anything else powers most people think
of energy and electricity as the same
thing but electricity is only 20
of the world's energy most of the
world's energy is dire is usually
directly burning fossil fuels because
that's really really good for say
heavy-duty transportation like cargo
ships and airplanes that are much more
efficient to burn fossil fuels directly
than versus any kind of electric battery
which is essentially impossible for
those
and then a lot generating huge amounts
of heat for industrial purposes which is
um
much more efficient using fossil fuels a
lot of the time so
the the thing is it should be pretty
crazy to think okay and solar and wind
provide three percent of the world's
energy all in the form of electricity
and that three percent is entirely
dependent on fossil fuels nuclear and
hydro namely controllable sources of
electricity so just the macro thing it
should be suspicious to people that the
thing that's three percent that totally
depends on the other things
is going to replace
all of the fossil fuels and plus provide
energy to the rest of the world in the
next 27 and a half years and then you
look at what actually happens in the
places that use these and you notice
that the when you look at the places
that are like significant swaths of area
that are consistently using more solar
and wind the prices go up
and the basic reason is because they're
unreliable
they can go to near zero at any given
time
what you have is is you have to pay for
the 100 reliable grid and then you also
have to pay for the solar wind so you
can think of these as infrastructure
duplication costs and so
those mount up and what happens is
either you're willing to pay those costs
like say germany has been willing to and
you have very expensive electricity or
you try to cut back on those costs by
cutting back on your reliable
controllable sources such as nuclear
natural gas which is what's happened in
texas and what's happened in california
in texas in particular it's been a lack
of investment in let's say
weatherization and other kind of
resiliency measures
and so
then you have reliability problems so
you can have quite a bit of solar and
wind and be totally reliable if you're
willing to have the 100 backup but it's
very very costly so what you see is
these things are cost adding sources of
electricity so
there's just there's no basis at all for
thinking that oh these are going to
rapidly replace fossil fuels they don't
have any of the trajectory of that what
you would want is you'd want something
that was really replacing fossil fuels
that didn't depend on fossil fuels that
was out competing them without any
government favoritism including
subsidies and mandates and that was
expanding into all the areas that are
non-electricity such as industrial heat
such as heavy duty transportation and
none of this is happening at all so i
talked about this in a lot of detail in
chapter six of fossil future but if you
just look at the the trajectory of these
things doesn't res doesn't remotely
resemble the unprecedented economic
breakthrough
and then a final thing that's notable is
the people who claim to support solar
and wind so enthusiastically
there's something very phony about it
because they're not just hostile to
fossil fuels they're usually hostile in
nuclear
they're hostile to hydro and they're
hostile to mining
and
solar and wind require more mining than
essentially any project ever conceived
in the history of humanity because
they're very dilute sources in addition
to intermittent so they take up a lot of
space you need to
you need to mine these things called
rare earths that they're not rare in the
earth but they're low low concentrations
you need to mine a huge amount of
material to get small amounts of them
and so what's really going on
is and this where it's come back it
comes back to philosophy is really the
movement behind this their goal i argue
is to eliminate human impact on earth
they think it's evil for us to impact
the earth and they want to reduce or
eliminate that impact and that's why
they're hostile not just to fossil fuels
but also to things that you would expect
them to love like nuclear and hydro and
the mining necessary for solar and wind
and so i consider
the enthusiasm for solar and wind to be
a pretext for just hostility toward
energy as such
um because it doesn't yeah because it
doesn't present as we love energy so
much and we're just so enthusiastic
about this particular form it presents
as we always have a reason to be against
every form of energy and here's the
latest thing we're pretending to be for
even though we're against all the
industrial processes that would make it
possible if it were possible which it's
not well one of the other big criticisms
is that carbon in the atmosphere is
going to not only impact the climate
moving forward but turn us into a
post-apocalyptic wasteland
why why are you so confident that this
isn't going to be the case why should we
why does the ledger balance out in favor
of fossil fuels when there is so much
concern around the parts per million and
carbon in the atmosphere
yes i think this is really the thing
that that drives it and that drives good
people on it you know it's this concern
that well the side effect of using this
is going to be the apocalypse i mean the
way aoc put it is you know scientists
have told us we've got 12 years to live
and you're if we don't do something and
you're worried about the cost and so i
would say it's a totally legitimate
thing to look into because you burn
fossil fuels it it releases energy but
it also releases um co2 in the
atmosphere co2 is a warming gas and a
fertilizing gas for that matter and so
it's legitimate to look into hey what
are the consequences of this but
if you look at the way people think
about it um the way you would think
about it from a pro-human perspective so
if your goal is to advance human
flourishing you recognize the earth is a
delicate nurture and you look at both
the benefits and side effects
with precision it doesn't at all
resemble
how people think of it so the way you
would think of it is there are basically
three principles you should follow when
thinking about co2 and our leaders
follow almost
none of these if you find somebody who
follows even two of these principles you
found yourself a good thinker uh and
what's interesting is nobody has ever
disagreed with any of these principles
but almost nobody follows
so principle one is when you're looking
at co2
you need to look carefully at the
positives and negatives of the co2
itself so co2 is a side effect of fossil
fuels but you have to be open to
positive and negative impact so it's a
warming gas and a fertilizing gas so one
thing is you need to look seriously at
what are the greening benefits of that
which turn out to be very significant
and then with warming you need to be
open to
warming
could be good overall particularly
because if you look at the science it
tends to occur more in the colder parts
of the world where people tend to want
it to be warm tends to occur more at
night than during the day tends to occur
more during the you know winter months
than summer months and then by the way
patrick moore who might i know you've
had on one reason i admire him and i've
i've done some things with him is like
he's one of the few people actually
looks at co2 from this kind of
open-minded pro-human way versus what's
the normal thing we look at we assume
that oh my gosh we since we created the
co2 it must be evil it must be ruining
everything and we don't think at all
about the benefits of greening even
though it's called the goddamn green
movement and yet they don't talk about
the benefits of turning the planet from
brown to green which has happened
magnificently in the last 40 years in
most parts of the planet and then
warming is we have way more people who
die of cold than of heat so you should
at least grow
yeah oh it's for true by a large margin
yeah it's all this stuff is in
is in fossil fuel and also
if you want the points for free a lot of
them are energytalkingpoints.com i have
references there yeah so the planet is
way too cold now i know you're in austin
so you're not experiencing this
um at the moment but you know we're
tropical species we tend to do better in
warmer climates yeah even in india more
people die of cold
than of heat no way
yeah dude that's wild chapter uh i think
chapter seven and eight
one of those gives that that primary
source so so the the one thing is
and then also just with the co2 i'll get
to the other stuff but like we also know
if you know any history of the planet
like co2 has been way higher than it is
now it's been 10 plus times higher
temperatures don't correlate at all
perfectly with co2 historically but
we've also had temperatures that are
like 14 degrees celsius 25 degrees
fahrenheit warmer and life on earth
thrived and we're the most versatile
adaptable species in history so this
idea of the planet is going to burn and
become uninhabitable on its face is
insane what you can say is that more co2
will make the planet more tropical and
you can be worried about
whether there will be a disruptive trend
rate of transition from a less tropical
planet to a more tropical planet like
that's a legitimate thing but this idea
of apocalypse the world is going to end
if it becomes more tropical this is just
total
um
nonsense and so then so that's just
principle one you have to look at co2
the positives and negatives with
precision and people don't do that
um but then the other two which i'll go
through quickly so with one you need to
look at all the benefits of fossil fuels
which i mentioned our leading thinkers
don't including for things like
agriculture but then the third thing
that was the most
had the most effect on me is that you
need to look at what i call the climate
mastery benefits of fossil fuels so if
you're talking about fossil fuels and
climate yes the co2 has impacts on
climate
but using energy allows you to have a
certain level of mastery over climate
and a very significant level of of
mastery so you take like
take like cold i think about i like
snowboarding and snowmobiling so i go to
utah the snowboard snow bird area to do
those things and you think about that is
those used to be treacherous areas right
those were a negative but now the snow
in utah is a positive because we have
such a level of mastery where we can
enjoy it for fun but we're protected
from
you know the adverse parts of it or you
take a thunderstorm right a thunderstorm
that used to be able to destroy your
house can now be the romantic setting
for a date so like human beings mastery
of climate is such that we can not only
neutralize or reduce negatives we can
actually turn a negative into a positive
what what is actually positive a
negative climate always depends on your
level of mastery and if you look at
fossil fuels it's unbelievable what we
can do i mean we can alleviate drought
we can do irrigation which is a
magnificent thing that's
under-appreciated we can of course but
it's under-appreciated we can make it
cool when it's hot we can make it warm
when it's freezing cold we can have
storm warning systems and so if you if
you just think about it logically fossil
fuels have these amazing benefits of the
more energy you use
the more you can use machines to protect
yourself from climate and yet
how many people talk about this when
they're talking about fossil fuels and
climate they assume that the co2 is just
apocalyptic which there's no reason to
believe that and then they ignore our
ability to master
any negatives of it and the the data
point that most changed my thinking and
many others is that if you look at the
if you actually quantify what's been
happening as we've been using more
fossil fuels emitting more co2 the world
has warmed one degree celsius two
degrees fahrenheit
we have we can chronicle or um
we can document how many people are
dying from climate-related disasters
such as storms and flood extreme
temperatures and the rate of
climate-related disaster that's is down
98
over the last century and it's like
it's crazy like we're so much safer from
climate than we used to be and yet
nobody talks about this so this this
just should what i'm really trying to
impress upon people is that the way that
our not just dumb people but the smart
allegedly the smartest people on this
issue
who are specialists in this issue and
those are just who are smart
commentators think about this issue in a
way that makes no sense at all because
they ignore the benefits of fossil fuels
and they
in climate and elsewhere and they what i
call catastrophize the side effects so
they they assume that the side effects
are going to be really bad and they
ignore our ability to master them and
and
if you get that there's something very
wrong in our leading thinkers then your
mind gets open to the possibility hey
maybe this is one of those times in
history
when quote the experts are wrong well
and it is the obvious question is why
does everyone believe this if it's not
true
why does everyone believe it if it's not
true yeah yeah why does everyone believe
that there's going to be this apocalypse
if
there is strong evidence that seems
pretty logical that that's not the case
well i think it comes down to the the
framework so i mentioned so the first
thing i try to do
in my work and in this book in
particular is you know chapter one is
called ignoring benefits chapter two is
called catastrophizing side effects
and so what i try to establish first is
look our leading thinkers what i call
our designated experts like these people
are clearly ignoring the benefits of
fossil fuels there's no way of getting
around this we can ask why which i talk
about in chapter three but i first i
need to establish that this is happening
and so we know if you're ignoring the
benefits of say a prescription drug
you're not going to make a good decision
about the prescription drug and if for
some reason
a society as a whole ignores the
benefits of some you know medical
intervention or exaggerates the side
effects there's going to be they're
going to make bad decisions
and then the second thing is called
catastrophizing the side effects
catastrophizing side effects rather and
that shows that there's a history with
the side effects of fossil fuels
of
of assuming that there will be a
catastrophic consequence and in fact
life improves so we have a documented
history of our leaders predict
catastrophic resource depletion we have
more resources than ever catastrophic
pollution we have higher environmental
quality catastrophic global cooling
catastrophic global warming we have
record safety from climate-related
disaster so
the first thing i just try to establish
is look this is happening there's
something really wrong with the way
people are thinking about it then we can
get to why but i like to establish first
that there's something wrong going
methodologically and then we can talk
about what's what's driving that but
first people need to agree am i thinking
about this the right way and are these
people thinking about it the right way
and then
and then sort of chapter three is trying
to answer that why why is this and it's
those those issues i mentioned before so
one is this idea of the delicate nurture
so if you believe earth is a delicate
nurturer and human impact is inevitably
self-destructive
the benefits of fossil fuels will always
seem ephemeral
and the side effects you will always
expect to be catastrophic so that's why
we've had 50 years of leaders telling us
we face catastrophe but we still think
it's going to be
catastrophe it's like if you if you earn
a certain religion and the prophet keeps
protect predicting the end of the world
as long as you're in that religion and
you accept this prophet
you are going to keep expecting the end
of the world because that's your whole
view
of life and then the other thing which
this is what is a little harder to
swallow
is i think that that most of our leading
thinkers and
sort of by accident most of us do not
think about this issue in a pro-human
way namely when we're thinking about
fossil fuels and their impact on the
world and climate
our goal is not we're not thinking about
it from the perspective of how do we
advance human flourishing on earth we're
really thinking about it in terms of how
do we imp how do we eliminate human
impact so with climate in particular
we're not thinking about how do we keep
as many people as possible safe from
climate because if you were thinking
about that you would think a lot about
energy and mastering climate we just
think about how do we stop emitting this
evil co2
and we have this assumption it's just
it's just wrong for us we shouldn't be
impacting climate there's just something
deeply wrong and i think we have a huge
amount of guilt over that
and and therefore you look at our
society and we're trying to eliminate
this one gas
at all costs and i think the underlying
thing there is yeah we're not really
valuing human flourishing we're valuing
this idea of eliminating our impact and
there's a lot of
ways that innocent good people end up
doing that but i think in practice we
are not actually looking at fossil fuels
from a human flourishing perspective but
the good news is most people think we
should so i think part of the reason i'm
able to convert a lot of people is most
people do agree with thinking about this
issue in a pro-human way they just
haven't been taught to do it and they
haven't seen that the way we're doing it
makes no sense unless you hate humans if
you hate humans the way we think about
fossil fuels makes total sense
because
if you ignore the benefits of a key
source of energy and catastrophize the
side effects then you'll use a lot less
energy and then a lot more people will
die and then we'll have much less impact
on the planet
but if your goal is not to eliminate
impact on the planet but for human life
to flourish on the planet
then fossil fuels are great
obviously this is a very passionate
topic that a lot of people have pinned
their colours to the flagpole of yes
what are the
what are the most common criticisms that
you get about your position
so it's been interesting seeing reviews
and stuff i mean i'm still hoping to get
more and people can
i'm trying to answer this in a way that
doesn't sound totally self-serving
because i'm really unimpressed
with the criticisms
uh
because because i think like
there are three let me put it this way
like i think i can criticize myself
better than the existing people can
uh that i've tried but so the basic
things i i could be wrong on three
things i think theoretically i could and
you've raised two of them so i could be
wrong on
like i'm thinking about climate wrong
somehow like i'm wrong and particularly
like the climate side effects of fossil
fuels will be far worse and they'll
overwhelm our ability
to master them i could be wrong about
that i mean hypothetically i could uh i
could be wrong about the ability of
solar and wind to rapidly replace fossil
fuels and i could be wrong about the
importance of energy like those are the
three because those are my three things
right i'm saying energy is really
people people say like yeah energy is
okay but who really cares about the cost
of energy and i say no the livability of
the planet for human beings depends on
the cost of energy the lower cost energy
is the more you use machines to be
productive and prosperous the better
life is so like i think it's fundamental
but people could argue no it's not that
important other things are more
important
from a human flourishing perspective i'd
say those are the three things i could
be wrong about or i could be wrong that
we should be focused on human
flourishing and that and somebody could
but but interestingly most people won't
oppose me on those grounds which i would
like to see that or or they could say
yeah no the planet is much more of a
delicate nurturer than you acknowledge
nobody has ever said yeah i agree we
should ignore the benefits of fossil
fuels and catastrophize
the side effects but they some do say
well i don't agree with your definition
of benefit because i think benefits
should be
how does this benefit eliminating human
impact on earth and that would be an
honest thing but most people what i
would love is if some people said hey
you know what i think you value human
life too much
and i value it less and that's why
you're wrong like i would accept that
the response to most of what i do i find
is
straw manning my view so saying things
like oh alex just he just wants fossil
fuels and that's all he cares about even
though i'm you know one of the most
pro-nuclear people in the world and i'm
for energy freedom so if we look at um
say slate wrote a quote review and um
foreign policy wrote a review
and it's just like you can't even
recognize my arguments
in these things so i don't think most
for me a good review is you accurately
summarize the person's view and you say
hey this is what's wrong with it not you
just write random stuff that no one
would have any idea what's actually in
the book and then you attack
that what about the people on the
internet that say you're a paid lobbyist
for the
fossil fuel industry and that you're
being funded by them so that they don't
lose money and they continue to get to
pump out co2 into the atmosphere and no
one gets to stop them well so that i
mean that as a form of argument is
obviously pretty weak form of argument
right because i have a book and it has
primary sources so even if that were
true you would still need to answer that
so it's a pretty weak thing but yeah so
kind of my i talk about this in the book
but like i have a fairly
clear path on this like i didn't know
anyone in the industry and i came up
with all these conclusions i had no
certainly no funding so i came up with
all of these ideas
and i tested them against people and i
debated them against people and i was
quite poor for a long time advocating
them
and then at some point
more and more people started seeing the
merit of them first outside industry and
then some inside industry and so yeah
now for sure i mean i i give talks to
companies and i charge money for those
talks and that's great and i'm proud of
that and i sometimes do consulting for
companies and like but yeah that's
that's
i'm doing that because i think it's it's
the right thing to do which is what i've
done regardless of my financial
relationship so yeah no i this idea that
the fossil fuel industry like funded me
to come up with these ideas i wish they
were that clever uh to have done that
within it with other uh with other
people but i think i think that that's
that argument shows a there's no
interest in actually learning the truth
about me b it's pretty weak if that's
what you have to go after
uh people for and then i there was a c
but i forgot what it was some other weak
aspect certainly one of the things that
i've seen a lot of i did a clip with
jordan peterson about population
collapse is coming and it went like just
super hyper viral and yeah i got to see
a lot of
comments
there
we didn't discuss
really why it might be happening but one
of the most prominent
uh sentiments that i saw in the comments
of that was this
scourge of the earth human racism
um
the earth's got way too many people on
it um it would be better off without us
like very very sort of apocalyptic
self-hating
uh and i was super surprised i don't
know what corners of the internet that
video had expanded itself out into to
pick up these sorts of comments but
i was really really surprised to hear
that i think
based on what i know the carrying
capacity of the earth is when we're not
really at the limit of that and that's
not really too much of a concern at the
moment
but
people were so quick
to say how much they hated the fact that
they themselves and presumably everybody
that they love and care about
live at the moment and that their future
generations as well i was so surprised
with that sentiment that that really
shocked me
so it relates to this issue i call it
the delicate nurture view of the earth
and so an aspect of delicate nurture i
talk about this a lot in chapter three
is what i call the parasite polluter
view of humans and i think that's really
what's captured in these kinds of
comments so it's the view that human
beings basic effect on the earth is we
parasite it so we just depend on it and
we plunder its resources and then we
pollute it we make it
ugly and and dirty and unhealthy in this
kind of thing
and
you know my view is what i call the
producer improver view for it so we
actually produce new value and we tend
to improve it from for our perspective
but from our perspective and also
sometimes from the perspective of many
other animals so you know we're we're
humans it's important like as humans
you um
like any organism you have both a
competitive and cooperative relationship
with the rest of nature and so advancing
human flourishing on earth doesn't mean
you hate the rest of nature you you love
the potential of nature but you want to
have a mute you want to have the most
pro-human relationship
with the uh
with the rest of nature and i think
like if you really recognize hey wait
the earth so you think of just this idea
of the producer versus the parasite
versus the producer like
is it really true that the earth had all
these amazing resources and we depleted
them and if so why was everyone so poor
for so long and you just think about
resources and the actual nature so
resource is just something that's
available to consume that benefits you
but where do resources come from the
vast majority of resources are produced
by human beings and what they are is
there some form of raw matter
and energy
transformed into more valuable form so
you take aluminum i'll always ask hey is
aluminum a valuable natural resource
people say yeah of course no it's not
it's not naturally resource aluminum is
naturally useless it's one of the most
abundant
metals there is but it wasn't useful 300
years ago at all same with oil same with
gas same with coal certainly uranium
which has been become even more
recently useful so if you think of the
earth as a ball of raw matter and energy
and how much resource and there's always
energy coming in i mean there's sun
coming in uh there's also you know all
kinds of this the rest of space and
all kinds of other resources but if you
just think of it as effectively an
unlimited ball of matter and energy
and then how much
the level of resource depends on the
state of human intelligence how much we
know how to transform that matter energy
into valuable resources you you stop
becoming a you stop becoming afraid of
running out
of resources and you become worried
about running out of freedom because you
see that when people don't have the
freedom to create resources that's the
problem so that's you look at the poor
parts of the world you ask what's the
carrying capacity of the earth carrying
capacity is a is not really a scientific
concept because it it it thinks of the
earth as this like petri dish and we're
bacteria and the petri dish can only but
it's really there's this limitless
potential that's only limited by our
mental
uh powers but if you look at what's the
carrying capacity of a poor part of
sub-saharan africa well it's very low
because their transformative abilities
are very low and that's part of the
reason why they need better forms of
energy and they need free
free societies and it once you think of
it that way you become much happier and
much more optimistic
and it's it's one of the gifts
i think i can give to the world is just
actually having a true philosophy of the
earth and humans
like you can actually appreciate how far
we've come
and how far we can go and then your fear
then becomes relocated and will diminish
but also relocated to
impositions on freedom because then you
see oh we've got this amazing world but
it depends on freedom and we see this
now with we have a supply chain crisis
why didn't we have one before well we've
we don't have as much freedom we have an
energy crisis we don't have as much
freedom but then it's you don't think oh
the world is mad at us or
nothing can happen
there's no good in the world it's just
oh yeah we restricted our freedom
and that's the root of our ability to
create resources and that's why it sucks
in this to this extent but if we
liberate people then it'll get really
good again and then it'll get better
i'm a big
existential risk
uh
garage hobbyist in terms of yeah i
remember from last time yeah in terms of
learning about that have you had any
more ideas about why it is that climate
change continues to be you know we've
just come out the other side of a
pandemic
and toby odds book the precipice has
this fantastic table where he breaks
down all of the different likelihoods of
the next hundred years of us going
extinct due to
every different type of super volcanoes
and
neutron stars and then anthropogenic
risks as well so you know bioweapons
leaks and
misaligned ai and nanotechnology and
unknown unknowns and all this stuff and
climate change is like i think it's one
in ten thousand
over the next hundred years and you've
got one in
sixes and one in tens one in ten natural
pandemic one in ten
ai over the next hundred years
what is it
what is it that's causing
everybody to be so blind to
what appear to be
from the researchers much more severe
concerns especially in the wake of us
just having seen one of them up close
and personal
i think it's because it's really become
a religion i mean i talk about it as a
philosophy but if you so i think of what
i taught the anti
rather the human flourishing framework
but then the dominant framework is what
i call the anti-impact framework which
is basically you can think of it as
the the one sentence summary is is human
impact on earth is bad and there are two
components one is it's evil so it's an
evil thing and our goal should be to
eliminate it and the then the idea is
it's inevitably self-destructive because
impacting the delicate nurturer ruins
everything so if you think of human
impact as intrinsically immoral and
inevitably self-destructive well it ha
that has a very religious quality to it
right because it's the god in this case
is the unimpacted earth some you know
some people call it gaia but they
usually
they'll talk about like the climate but
it has this god-like quality
to it and the idea is that the
commandment is basically thou shalt not
impact nature and then the idea is if
you impact nature then nature punishes
you
and you go to hell i mean that's really
it's got all of these these things got
rituals like recycling and stuff that
you're not very clear on like what the
ritual does but it's like this is what
everyone is doing right now and that's
the
so it has and you look at people are
now there's this argument well there's a
lot of arguments around does this is
this replacing religion for people do
you need religion as the opposite so i'm
a non-religious person i don't think you
need religion to
oppose this but it does have the quality
of a religion and for some people it's
it's a substitute
in their lives and so that's a
that's a pretty entrenched thing
for people and and maybe the most
important aspect is it has this very
strong moral dimension of just we're
doing the wrong thing
whereas with pandemics people don't
think of it as we're doing the wrong
thing i think of it as okay this is a
this is mostly
there's some exception to that i should
say because people did kind of get like
that during the pandemic but in general
with pandemics they think
we're doing
like this is a practical threat or if
you think about like an electromagnetic
pulse this is a practical threat or a
meteor this is a practical threat
and then yeah if if people think i guess
if people think the threat is real and
we're ignoring it then it has yeah
you're doing the wrong thing but it's
not like your life's mission
to do this versus for some people it's
like their life's mission to protect the
climate or to serve the earth or to save
the earth is this kind of thing so i
think it's got this this religious moral
dimension that the other things don't
have and that's a big driver one of the
things that i've come to believe about
it is that it's a little bit more
obvious
of a concern for people to be galvanized
around so ai is being done by
some blokes somewhere in some computer
lab writing code no one can see it the
takeoff is incredibly rapid the same
goes with viruses even when they're here
you can't actually see the virus you can
see the effect of the virus but you
can't see it you can't see it mutating
in a pangolin or in a lab in wuhan you
you can't see it doing its thing
and then
it happens one of the reasons i think
that it's so galvanizing for people is
that you can the imagery is so obvious
uh to put in front of them here is a
power plant and here is some smoke and
here is a burning forest like it's it's
just from a marketability standpoint
it's it's
good maybe the maybe the forest but it's
it's interesting because a lot of it is
remote stuff so the polar bear stuff is
very remote i mean you can that you can
show an image of the polar bear but in a
sense an energy crisis is much more
immediate a pandemic is much more
immediate in terms of this so i think
it's partially that the religious
quality makes people evaluate things as
it's not just this is practically scary
to me but this is really like this
vengeful nature of god punishing us it's
like we did the wrong thing so you take
take something like um
wildfires when people think about
wildfires inside california this is an
issue with some out-of-control wildfires
it's like the reaction to it is so much
like we did an evil thing and now we're
being punished versus okay what are the
dangers of this and what can we do as
modern human beings if you if you have
that edge you think okay well these
fires are fueled by a lot of uh what's
called fuel load and so we could reduce
the fuel load we could go back to
logging which we stopped for a bunch of
bad reasons you can clear brush you can
do controlled burns
one thing i talk about in chapter seven
a fossil future that's underrated you
can build barriers uh which can stop
things from spreading like you have all
these options it's not that complicated
to manage fires and to prevent them but
we don't have this we have this can't do
attitude with it versus the can-do
attitude that we have in other places
because i think there's just a huge
amount of guilt so when we hear about oh
this storm was bad or this flood was bad
or the temperature is too hot it's this
mixture of oh yeah it's a problem but
it's really like we did something bad
and we should feel guilty and this
expectation that what's going to come in
the future is just this huge retribution
because the practicality again
98 decline in climate-related disaster
tests climate has never been less of an
issue in people's day-to-day lives as a
practical matter think about what
climate was like during the dust bowl
think about climate right 100 years ago
you know how terrified you had to be of
climate let alone 200 years ago 300
years ago so it's really there is this
here's another perspective whenever
you're evaluating things there's always
the question of what's what standard are
you using to evaluate something is good
or bad and that ultimately depends on
your goals
and here we're evaluating climate
not by the standard of human flourishing
but by the standard of eliminating human
impact so we think our impact is bad and
so whenever we hear we've impacted
climate we think that's really bad and
we've been bad people and we're gonna
get we should repent we should be
punished but the i don't think anything
about the perceptibility of things
uh the actual threat of things i don't
think there's anything special about
climate
except that it has this religious
classification in people's minds
speaking about punishing on a personal
level you are more than just your uh
collection of ideas and books right
there's a human behind the words i'm
interested in working out how you deal
with being uh unpopular to a mainstream
um group of powerful people like the
atlantic tried to write a hit piece on
you washington post washington post
sorry a couple of i don't know whether
maybe the atlantic they're pro they're
probably coming down the line um they
tried to do one on you just before the
book came out like you're swimming
against the tide here how do you cope
with that
like contrarian space and and push back
and take down attempts and stuff like
that
so
i have a like a mental model in my head
that's really simple
but i find it very helpful and i don't
know if if other people would find it
helpful because it just seems too simple
but kind of like i have in my mind
before drawing you a picture there's
reality
and there's what's in people's heads
and i think of those as very different
like the job of our heads is to perceive
what's in reality and act accordingly
but like
the fact that something is in someone's
head by itself
has no guarantee whatsoever that it will
be true
in reality so
i just it doesn't and i know from
history that what's in people's heads
can be totally wrong in a way that we
think of as wrong so you could have you
know the designated experts of 100 years
ago believing in force sterilization
and racism and all these things and now
we would say some people still then
believed in slavery you know we'd say
those are evil i'm like okay that's just
further proof that whatever people
happen to think that doesn't mean it's
true at all so what's powerful to me is
did you give me evidence that what is in
your head
corresponds to reality so if somebody
when somebody says something like
alex you're a climate change denier
you know you're not a scientist blah
blah blah blah it's like
it's exactly the same for me as because
there's no content to those arguments or
no accuracy in the case of the climate
change it's exactly like said like if a
two-year-old said hey you idiot why
don't you believe in santa claus it's
like i get that you believe it but why
should i believe it and i think there's
just
it's very helpful to have a philosophy
where you just have a really clear-cut
distinction between what's true of
reality
and what's in people's heads and then
the things to be concerned about are
in some senses if they're right like if
they're writing sometimes they'll say
something that i'm wrong but then then
you shouldn't be concerned about that
because you can just change your view
i mean
that's another thing is just
you have to know i think that
the other thing is i know my like i have
a very deep commitment
to only to changing my beliefs
if somebody can prove me wrong and i had
this with a big issue when i was 18
whereas like i was making a big decision
about what i believed and i i like made
it i i thought to myself very explicit
like even if it was hard to change my
belief at the time um but i thought like
even if i'm 80 and i've dedicated my
whole life to something and somebody
tells me i'm wrong i will admit it
and it's like that's that's just a very
core belief that i will change my view
if i'm proven wrong and i know that
about myself
so i don't really have anything to fear
about being wrong
and all i care about is what's actually
true
and then and then i know i'm committed
to saying it to the best of my ability
so the worst anyone can do is show me
that i'm wrong about something now the
washington post the other thing they can
do is they can try to convince other
people of something false that makes my
life difficult so in the case of
washington post trying to convince
people that i'm a racist and therefore
you shouldn't listen to my ideas
like yeah that's annoying but it doesn't
hurt me personally it's just like okay
you guys are [ __ ] and i'm gonna
torch you in front of the world because
you you did this and and i and i
explained you know that we could talk
about that whole saga but that's that's
kind of
that didn't hurt me personally that was
just a strategic thing that i needed
to deal with but i think if you if you
really have this idea of you really
believe in objective reality and you
really have a a commitment to always
believe and say what you think is true
then
i would just say it's from my talking to
people the way i experience these things
is way different
than other people because i just don't
have like
people say things like you know for
every positive comment like i can get
100 positive comments on twitter but
then one negative one will like ruin my
week this is not my experience at all i
get so many negative comments on twitter
and it's just
if there's nothing to it it's just it's
like no it's really like the
two-year-old
it's like there are people who just
write on every post of mine they're like
you're not a scientist you're an idiot
blah blah blah blah you're just funded
you're just like
that's exactly like the two-year-old
with santa claus but if they say like
for example
and sometimes it can be
there's this guy that i think is a like
a pretty bad guy who might debate a name
andrew destler who is on joe rogan and
like he and i debated and he was wrong
about so many things and admitted none
of them and i kept making these points
and i think he's just so dishonest but
he he got one error in fossil future and
like i immediately publicly corrected it
and thanked him and this is a guy i
think is a bad guy and not an honest
actor but it's like
okay even in this case it's like the
truth is the truth and if even if a bad
person says it it's
it's fine it's just like no the thing i
was wrong about by the way is
there was a prediction in the new york
times by a guy named james hansen and it
turns out the new york times had
somewhat misrepresented his prediction
and i had not caught them on that so i
didn't change anything about my basic
point uh but nevertheless was an heirs
i'm like okay i'll cr correct that in
the next um edition but even that is
like that's just like oh [ __ ] i should
have looked into that more carefully
it's not
but i still know that i'm committed to
the truth and if he caught a big error i
would do it and if somebody proved me
wrong i would change it it wouldn't be
the most fun thing in the world but i
would
it seems like there's sort of two
elements here one is um
[Music]
feeling confident in your position
because that gives you a firm foundation
for
um self-doubt to not start to creep in
and then the other side of this is truth
at all costs
because that kind of makes you
invulnerable to whether or not you do
need to change your mind it's just
interesting
it's impressive that you haven't
that the self-doubt doesn't doesn't
creep in in this but the second the
second one is really what it is right
because it's just the confidence in the
in the position
is confidence in my process
because it's just confidence in how much
work i've done
to be right and to prove myself wrong
and to surround myself with people who
will challenge me to take criticism like
if you have if you have that level of
exposure to all these pressures and you
deal with them honestly then
i at least know i've done my best to be
right and again i know i'll change my
view
so it's it's the it's the confidence
that what i'm doing
is right so i never have any doubt about
like am i doing the right thing on a
moral level and i don't have any
specific but it's the level at which i
have tried to be right
i think is
very unusual and i think what happens is
some people never try to be right like
they're just lie they just grow up in a
certain political environment it's just
they just kind of
try to reinforce what they grew up with
i had the benefit of
my parents are kind of in the political
world a little bit but they never forced
anything on me so i kind of got to
choose from the beginning what to think
and there was never any pressure to
think of something but even there i
changed my views
uh a bunch of times so it's it's so some
people never try and then other people i
think what happens is
you come to a view
and then you get then you like all of
your status
and your friends like they're all in
this view and you really think about it
you start to think about it in a tribal
way and in an identity way and that is a
real hazard but i think that's why you
really need the commitment that your
core identity is saying what you is
believing what you think is true and
saying what you think is true
and a big part of that which you can
spot in people is how precise are they
so like i'll give an example of without
naming any names like um
there are people i'm allied with let's
say there's somebody i'm allied with
that i like a lot who posted something
viral the other day
um and i thought it was like 80 true
and
and 20
not right and i thought well okay i
would like to i'm excited that it's
viral
but i can't share it because there's 20
percent of it that's just misleading and
i don't want to
share that and it's kind of like yes
this person is my ally but like we're
only allies in so far as we really align
on the truth it's not like i'm part of
this movement and they represent me and
i represent them
i think it's
you should be very wary of just all of
these movements and things that you
align with because ultimately i think
you should align with
your own like your job is to pursue
truth
as you said you really do have to be
careful this is the one legitimate
concern about the financial stuff is
more like
do people get locked into things like
you say say like somebody who's a known
as a liberal becomes more conservative
and then a whole bunch of money starts
flowing toward them or vice versa you
know
you just need to be aware of those
things in yourself and i think one thing
if you're if you're an ideas person is
you really need to think about how do
you set up your incentives
and your your income such that you have
the freedom to change your views quite a
bit and i
that's been a big thing i've thought
about in my life is how
how i can
my views can change and i'll be totally
fine are there any other mental models
that you wish more people knew stuff
that you've picked up that you really
rely on to make sure that your life's
going right
yeah i mean
it's an unlimited uh amount so i have a
podcast people want to know how i think
about these things called the human
flourishing project which i have i think
98 episodes of so
a lot of things there i mean i'm very
into philosophy i think um
you know i'm very into what's called
objectivist philosophy so ein rand i
think that
is think one of my huge advantages is
that i
understood pretty early on how
good a thinker she was and i don't think
most smart people do and so that's made
me
that's just given me some huge
advantages over other people i think um
i think when you're told to read ein
rand usually it's
it's usually like this is a crazy thing
that you really shouldn't agree with or
maybe you'll like it when you're 18.
um
i read some letters of hers like there's
a book of her correspondence when i was
18 i read letter to barry goldwater
and i was like oh my gosh this is the
smartest person i've ever seen in my
life like this person is on a totally
different level than anyone either
just be on the internet somewhere that
people can go and look at i don't know
if it's on the internet it's in the book
letters of iron rand it's just the
letter to
barry goldwater i mean the the specific
thing that i remember was just
um
she was i think he had a book called the
conscience of a conservative that she
was uh criticizing and she just made
this point among others that like the
founding fathers were not conservatives
they were revolutionaries but i just
remembered her she was challenging the
the use of terminology in a very
rigorous way which maybe that sounds
familiar for people who know my work but
like
she would just challenge the terms and
have a very clear term for everything
that she
did and just think
almost nobody
almost nobody does that so i feel like
that was a big
again i would highly i'd highly
recommend um i mean i think the
fountainhead i think i told you the
fountain has the best self-help book
ever written so i think anyone who wants
to be happy should read the fountainhead
and anyone wants to understand the world
should read out shrugged and then she
has a number of non-fiction books she
unfortunately never wrote a full book
about her whole philosophy but i think
of that as just this
um
it's not like
nothing that exists is like the
comprehensive you just read this and
everything in your life will be amazing
but it'll definitely be some good things
to think about um
and it's
so yeah i would say the two i would say
reading on rand and then my own stuff in
this is is mostly covered in human
flourishing
project and then i'll write some i'll
write a book on relaxed productivity at
some point soon and then you should read
that i'm down man alex epstein ladies
and gentlemen uh if people want to check
out all of the other stuff that you do
where should they go
okay if you want the book uh get it in
all your book purchase or whatever you
want learn about stuff fossil future dot
com uh twitter is my most active place
so at alex epstein
and i have a website called
energytalkingpoints.com where you can
get my newsletter
and get the best talking points on in my
view on every current um
issue so that should be plenty for
people alex i appreciate you man
all right good to see you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you